j'ai fait la connerie de rendre service
à un ami du siècle de choplin sakho que
jean revinrent à cuba ouais
et il ya quelques années il m'a demandé
s'il est très correcte et ce avec
tripoli très poli et il m'a demandé
d'aller lui chercher de 3 mallette way
et on m'explique que c'est interdit mr
des gens très correct à nanterre ils
m'ont laissé dormir à la maison et j'ai
retourne après quoi donc
dépêchons-nous
jeu là
c'est le warm up
[Musique]
ça valide y est ça va bien ce qui peut
lui parler normalement
ça va dit gay ah bah oui ça va vous avez
vu le film
priscilla folle du désert qui est sorti
en france en
1995 et aujourd'hui c'est devenu une
comédie musicale qui est sur scène à
paris et je vous l'offre vous faire
sourire pour vous mettre de bonne humeur
je vous offre priscilla
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien voilà où
vivre
il sort
[Musique]
et qui ravit
nous serons
là
[Musique]
jusqu'à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais là
hu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
zuma
n'est ce pas
c
[Musique]
ça
gratuit
[Musique]
d'ailleurs n'est-ce pas
ouattara
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il aa
voilà
rabbo
on sait où
y aller dit la vérité et je reviens du
brésil
alors priscilla folle du désert donc au
casino de paris jusqu'au 7 avril et
ensuite du 30 mai au 7 juillet alesis un
spectacle fantastique
je
[Musique]
voilà
le vol du bourdon et violent et bien non
pas le viol le vol du plomb dans l'ailé
ce qui compte cinq alors ça vous dépayse
pas tellement je vous avais joué la cage
aux folles avec christian clavier avec
beaucoup de succès donc finalement vous
êtes dans votre événement un dj qui
c'est un ami à moi laurent bertho qu'à
paris ce soir sur l'a2 excellent bravo
en tout les cas voilà
alors
didier bourdon gt alberto à la fiche de
la pièce les inséparables
mise en scène de ladislas chollat donc
avec vous il ya valérie karsenti thierry
frémont pierre-yves bon evil diamants
alors c'est votre grand retour sur les
planches donc dix ans après la cage aux
folles qui était un triomphe avec
christian clavier alors le pitch vous
êtes gabriel orsini un artiste peintre
d'environ 50 ans en pleine crise
existentielle
en panne d'inspiration
marié avec une femme qu'il ne supporte
plus et là miracle
voilà vous héritez vous a été d'un
magnifique ateliers de la part d'une
femme inconnue et en passant la porte de
cet atelier vous faites un saut dans le
temps et vous devenez votre grand père
samuel banquiers qui avaient acheté en
fait cet atelier pour sa maîtresse une
peintre russe du nom de sacha voilà ça
un pitch très intéressant oui c'est beau
puis bien évidemment le personnage
contemporain n'est pas au courant de
cette histoire le rhin il a seulement un
souvenir un peu noir dans son grand père
qui était un peu son père dans son
twitter il va découvrir en fait c'est un
secret de famille qu que cet homme a été
dit complètement différent de ce qu'il
était depuis qu'il a été aussi meurtri
par un on va pas tout raconter plein
donc jouer les deux rôles valérie
karsenti joue la monte de 2 samuel donc
du grand père les deux histoires
s'entremêlent sur scène on est assez
bien fait d'ailleurs dire est qu'on le
ressent bien parce que bien évidemment
les auteurs sont aussi un petit peu
malade il va là ils font venir le drame
au moment où il ya le plus grand bonheur
et ça mélange rires et larmes et à la
fin on sent bien qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émotion on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
cette femme parfaite inconnue a décidé
de léguer son atelier j'ai trouvé ça
excellent
latex est très beau il ya une profondeur
aujourd'hui c'est un mâle terne entre
émotion suspense tous les catalogues de
mes expos mais non c'est une pièce qui
est très bien rythmé bien jouer d'abord
didier bourdon trouve génial il était
très bon dans les deux rôles c'est comme
ça que je les trouvais d'une profondeur
d'une sensibilité profonde et la
noirceur du voyage intérieur plus
éclatant que l'intensité du son valérie
karsenti kong
on connaissait d'autres registres j'ai
trouvé excellente très piquante
pétillant
je décore merveilleuse jamais vu ça au
théâtre le fait que sa tournée qu'on
fait on est plusieurs espaces dans un
seul espace finalement sacré un dîner
mis dans la pièce parfois on n'a pas
retrouvé dans un film n'est plus un
parti n'a jamais été un père tue trop
comme pas mais
ils savent eux
ces
travaux ne sont pas de petites
merveilles
les encyclopédies il me semble qu'on les
appelle ne sais pas
voilà les inséparables au caire
commerciaux avec didier bourdon qui
m'ont invité ce soir c'est vrai ce que
dit le spectateur c'est extrêmement
cinématographique finalement pour une
pièce de théâtre c'est vrai oui tout à
fait
c'est vrai que le fait que le décor
tourner il ya des fois vraiment on est
face au public et en fait on a
l'impression qu'on est pas la caméra
change et des regrets et c'est la
première pièce sur les balkany
le rôle dans une même pièce et quand un
cadeau pour un comédien oui ben voilà
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya une sorte de
tour de force au départ mais les
inconnues de faire plusieurs personnages
et des inconnus dans faisait 30 mandat
mais bien sûr c'est pas pour vous c'est
pas nouveau alors la dernière fois que
vous êtes venu dans cette émission
c'était pour l'art formation des
inconnus en 2014 les inconnus ont connu
un immense succès absolument
incroyable et aussi des déboires alors
on a commencé par le succès mais ça sera
plus long
marie thérèse
holidays la chambre
ce qui semble même c'est pour toi
[Musique]
c'est quoi le problème c'est la chose si
ce n'est pas l'agenda ici les chiffres
le régime perd c'est une étoile gilbert
donc on a décidé comme ça le cannet et
si un père pour ses pairs
blaga il a choisi c'est bien j'y vois
psg toi toi et pourquoi il a parlé la
journée les temps plein
jim waters
village et les bras d'esprit le planning
était repassé pair ou impair où j'ai
programmé germes en discuter ce bien
évidemment les inconnus c'est culte
c'est vraiment excellent on voit encore
là mais il ya eu les déboires et les
déboires des ajustements il y avait
toute une presse qui vous appréciez pas
c'est à dire une presse un peu télérama
disons pour aller vite qui vous apprécié
par vous en avez souffert de ça ben nous
on se rendait pas compte parce qu'elle
toi qui es pas les réseaux sociaux - ce
qui fait que même les émissions de télé
maintenant les gens me disent ah non non
on parlait que de ça à l'époque je
demandais monsieur des bermudes et alors
ça a marché faut voir on sait pas encore
donc on n'était pas trop au courant non
après non c'est sur les films oui mais
sur les films télérama par exemple avait
descendu les trois frères la sympathie
et un an plus tard sur canal + il avait
adoré donc
battez les ramasser le journal télé des
gens qui regardent pas la télé en fait
c'est pour ça non mais la plus belle
critique c'est
le temps c'est le temps là dernièrement
j'ai croisé un mec un peu snob et un
bureau de tabac on a enfin correct et
des chewing gum prévient et il m'a dit
ah j'ai revu la séance et 8 les inconnus
j'avoue qu'à l'époque j'avais pas trop
mais là je trouve ça bien
vous avez tout dit didier avec tout ça
les gens misent beaucoup de temps à
réaliser que étiez un bon un grand
acteur et je vous dis franchement il est
aussi bon dans un drame sur france 2
parle de la mort dans l'âme
l'histoire du père qui a tué son fils
est excellent petr 4 millions de
téléspectateurs sur france 2 quand vous
faites des comédies c'est aller be.com
ou garde alternée vous êtes super
marrant alors moi quand je dis ça ça n'a
pas vraiment d'importance mais quand
c'est gérard depardieu qu'il le dit ça
prend un autre relief
je pensais que
le bourdon avait quelque chose en plus
peut-être il a c'est un être tragique
qui peut jamais être heureux de la vie
difficile
voilà
mais c'est vrai un vrai acteur un peu
comme michel serrault comme celle ci où
il pouvait faire des rôles est hyper
comique les conneries quoi et garde à
vue genre avec jean yanne et puis après
il faisait garde à vue voilà c'est c'est
un peu pareil je trouve avec vous non
vous avez un côté dark attraper le
bourdon en anglais déjà
ça vient d'où ce côté dark est ce que
c'est le déracinement d'algérie sont non
non non je crois que la mélancolie c'est
quelque chose qu'ils contiennent et on
l'a où on l'a pas je dois dire que la
maturité vous atteignez un petit peu les
choses mais c'est vrai que j'ai toujours
été soit très joyeux soient ses traits
sans prendre de substances illicites ya
aussi votre père qui a trimé toute sa
vie chez edf etc a fini par un burn-out
qu'est ce que ça vous a déjà eu un mort
naturelle mais enfin il a eu une très
très belle carrière d'un évident non ce
qui aurait pu ne plus me rendre et c'est
que ans ronan d'algérie il a hésité
entre la sacem et edf il a choisi l'edf
ici le bois oui c'était plus qu on
abonde thierry maintenant que stéphane
guillon nous a grillé autant jouer la
transparence donc pour l'émission de ce
soir vous devrez pleurer une première
fois dans vingt secondes d'accord puis à
la minute 31 et à la minute 59 ya pas de
problème puisque tout le monde le sait
je pleure sur comment voilà
didier bourdon vous avez quand même une
nature qui est timide et solitaire vous
dites tous mes films racontent des
histoires de solitude c'est votre truc
quoi oui c'est à dire que dans le
comique c'est vrai que j'aime bien le
trajet que c'est sûr que quand même
quand on dit 100 patates dans les trois
frères 1 ou même le personnage de
stéphanie de monaco quand elle pleure
elle pleure vraiment et qui fait rire
les gens mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien
le comique dans le tragique c'est à dire
qu'au départ la situation est tragique
et c'est là que ça m'a bien dit là vous
êtes bon alors c'est vrai qu'à
l'adolescence des gros coup de blues
quand même non oui j'aime beaucoup la
poésie c'est vrai que je me suis fait la
réflexion depuis un bout de temps la
poésie et l'humour c'est un peu la même
chose c'est pas laurent baffie qui me
dira le contraire c'est une manière
d'esquiver la réalité de passe à prendre
en pleine point vous êtes quand même
quelqu'un d'extrêmement solitaire non
sur lutteur et de vivre non ce n'est pas
lui que non je vous dis que c'est
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que j'ai
préparé un simple
[Musique]
je vais vous dire ce que j'aime le plus
dans cette émission s'est passé des
simples la maire josiane franchement
cette chanson ça peut me résumer parce
que c'est ce côté rien que j'adore c'est
voilà je suis seul mais avec une barre
hlm et encore
voilà spéciale dédicace pour agnès jude
voilà alors donc voilà et là miracle
en irak la sueur avait miracle a eu un
miracle sur le tournage du film c'est
ans de mariage vous rencontrez mari
sandra alors c'est quand même marrant de
rencontrer le grand amour sur un film
qui parle de problèmes de couple en fait
ces pauses sur les trois frères
en vous voir garde alternée mes enfants
voilà ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même regarder quand même c'est un vrai
mal ça fait quinze ans que ça dure vous
avez deux magnifiques petites filles
ensemble le problème c'est que les deux
petites filles pensent que le papa c'est
pascal légitimus
elle a été un peu plus clair que l'autre
a ainsi croisé bernard
et puis a réussi dans votre famille
aussi bon bout donc va effectivement
c'est toujours là alors c'est marrant
parce qu'on se demande lequel est un
cocker quand on regarde
[Musique]
il
c'était énorme oeuf on se retrouve après
la saluer
[Musique]
salut à tous
je suis flatté
alors premier cas rien invité ce soir la
moustache qui fait trembler la vème
république
elle vit bnl
première therion invité ce soir elle est
mortelle elle a conquis le monde entier
elle vient d'espagne non ce n'est pas la
grippe c'est victoria
autres terriens avec elle ce soir il a
un nom qui pourrait laisser penser qu'il
est déprimé et pourtant il respire la
joie de vivre dj mon nom
autres terrien éviter ce sort celui que
l'on présenté comme le gars de parents
mode d'emploi et qu'on présente
désormais comme le gars qu'on voit dans
tous les films qui marchent arnaud
ducret
en p2 zaccheroni côté rien du samedi
soir celui qui a fui sa terre natale
cuba pour régner sur les nuits
parisiennes le mythique dj du palace guy
cuevas
quoi
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le groupe les grandes fortunes et le
hashtag
fc
[Musique]
à juste un truc après ça lui était rien
ce soir je vous invite à passer un
samedi soir applicable on regarde
[Musique]
ce soir je vous donne rendez vous dans
l'un des plus beaux mois famille la
nouvelle eve
avec jeff fan club comme bill tous les
yeux sont braqués sur d'hôpitaux n'a pas
les fonds de gaston ben and one to many
reland
laura l'occasion il m'a dit tu peux
avoir est génial et chevaliers du fiel
savard h et grave kamel le magicien je
n'attends lambin l'histoire pigalle
c'est toujours mieux car en histoire a
passé samedi soir à pigalle de côté
d'ivoire ofaci excellent inédit samedi
soir à pigalle présentée par thierry
ardisson ce soir à 21h succès me vois je
compte sur vous pour regarder samedi
soir gare franchement c'est pas mal
ouais c'est qu'à 21h après l'émission et
maintenant voici mon cdd comme villa
[Musique]
d
et que j'ai pas dit c'est que l'on fait
dans samedi soir à pigalle je partage
l'antenne avec mon ami tom villa qui est
formidable
je suis maître de cérémonie je suis le
maître de cérémonie et voilà tu es très
gentil voilà n'hésitez pas à ce soir il
ya samedi soir à pia ce à 21h sur ces 8
noeuds zappez pas imaginer que vous êtes
en corée du nord il vous avait qu'une
seule chaîne ça sera plus simple comme
ça
crée deux invités sur quatre ont joué
dans l'épreuve de prof de sport c'était
arnaud ducret didier qui était prof de
maths voilà on peut pousser délire plus
loin victoria qui était peut être prof
d'espagnol will oui je sais pas ça c'est
le surveillant général à la limite
laurent avec sa connaissance de la
nature et des animaux prof de sciences
oui et vous vivo de passer prof de
chimie
le premier invité thierry elle a giflé
un journaliste à cannes qui avait
critiqué le film dans lequel elle avait
joué sans l'avoir vu et ce soir vient
pour une pièce de théâtre que j'ai adoré
mesdames et messieurs victoria abril
[Musique]
victoria qui vient donc pour la pièce
paprika voilà paprika c'est son nom dans
la pièce c'est vrai pourquoi pas de les
camions et aux biens des prénoms de
fleurs ou de fruits aujourd'hui à des
clémentines des cerises des marguerites
des roses c'est obliger un moment on
arrive au aux condiments tu vas pas pris
cage se présente moutarde à l'ancienne
et sel de guérande
en scène la cites c'est tout le comme un
poème à ouais alors ce qui est bien avec
victoria abril allez un peu bavarde yann
moix a contacté ses bernardo
en fait c'est votre surnom dans la pièce
c'est votre surnom paprika voilà c'est
du coup je vous présente concombre la
carotte la bûche évidemment le kiwi et
la banane et moi c'est leur a dit voilà
donc ça c'est
alors le petit pitch de la pièce raconte
l'histoire d'un jeune homme de 28 ans
qui sonne à votre porte et qui prétend
être votre fils alors bien entendu il
faut trouver le bon moment pour annoncer
qu'elle fils deux voies par exemple ça
fait trois ans que j'attends il m'a
toujours pas reconnu
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche le
palace je sais je sais 88 une belle
brune non ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
tout si on en parlera face au juge moi
je suis comme laura smet je me laisse
pas marcher dessus
sinon plus spirituelle vedette qui est
notre deuxième invité il a était inconnu
puis connu avec les inconnus et
aujourd'hui les déconnant sans les
inconnus c'est didier bourda
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable comment une génération
été marquée par les inconnus c'était les
pionniers bon après leur époque y avait
trois chaînes et pas interne et donc
forcément voté zitrone c'était marrant
mais bravo quand même là et actuellement
il affiche de la pièce qui s'appelle les
inséparables un peu comme christine
angot et le xanax ils sont inséparables
et non dans le pièce vous héritez d'un
magnifique appartement voilà qu'une
femme que vous n'avez jamais vu donc
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler vous a
légué donc vous aussi vous connaissiez
liliane bettencourt s'est fort bien
là mediapart qui va venir voir la pièce
non mais ça en fait voilà c'est une
pièce en deux temps début contemporain
et ça bascule dans les années 50 donc ça
c'est bien pour le public faut y aller
jusqu'à la moitié de la pièce on peut se
mettre à fumer dans le théâtre
la moitié en euros et l'autre en anciens
francs c'est une grosse galère
[Applaudissements]
s'il est notre prochaine invitée et
vient chez nous deux fois par an un peu
comme la grippe mais en beaucoup plus
sympa sauf quand on est politique c'est
louis plenel
à la cette semaine c'était la semaine
des douits c'est sarkozy en garde à vue
pour lui c'est le dernier star wars avec
un saut de pop corn hill
ses surnoms mais c est louis fondateur
de mediapart qui a fêté ses dix ans il
ya pas longtemps il ya par 45
journalistes permanents quasiment autant
de pigistes voilà j'ai dû qu' il fallait
bosser avec une moustache tous les
employés devaient même les femmes
doivent avoir une moustache non ça c'est
une fille qui nous sommes ça c'est
terrible effet caillou c'est parce que
tu crois que c'est une vraie info et non
sensique news et bien des fois tu crois
que c'est une fête news et non c'est une
vraie info j'ai une technique très drôle
cette semaine j'ai lu que nicolas
sarkozy lui quand il fait une garde à
vue il a le droit de retourner dormir
chez lui je sais pas qui a trouvé ça ça
doit être le bord à fismes et passez
vous allez pour terminer nos derniers
invités mesdames et messieurs il a été
chanteur de gospel dans une autre vie
edwy plenel parce que lui et oui c'était
les village people c'est arnaud ducret
[Applaudissements]
annonc é qui joue dans les dents pipi et
olive oil à sa fin pour certaines
régions de france c'est laissant dans
pipi au lit et où dans d'autres c'est
les dents dans le vert et pipi au lit et
c'est la smit
non c'est les amplifie au lycée la
phrase évidemment qu'on dit aux enfants
avant qu'ils se coucher alors qu'est
vieux le lendemain matin c'est remets
tes dents et au nantes a fait pipi au
lit
je
n'aurais alors le pitch du film voilà
vous êtes en colocation arnaud et votre
ancien colocataire trouve une nouvelle
colocataire pour pour le remplacer et
c'est louise bourgoin pendant un bonne
nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle arrive avec
ses deux enfants voilà c'est dommage que
soyez pas tomber sur victoria abril
parce que ces gamins sont déjà grands
elle adore se balader à poil au cinéma
c'est
là que je me suis permis parce que
arnaud c'est le seul sur le plateau car
un compte instagram j'étais un peu j'ai
un compte moins de grains ouais mais bon
alors le compte instagram tiens regarde
et il va faire le biopic d'edwy plenel
demandé la voix d'ailleurs sa nouvelle
croatie alors il ya une particularité
charneau c'est que quand il fait un
excès de vitesse il le montre à tout le
monde sur 100 il ya 150 ans en photo
aphatie si mon beau-frère bosse à la
gendarmerie tu auras de points on n'est
pas moi qui conduis c'est pas toi non
non y'a pas
arnaud a retrouvé le petit canard de
victoria abril qui est un peu grossier
d'ailleurs
y'a pas mal et puis alors arnaud laiter
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est quand il
va dans une piscine ouais il prend des
bouées
certains prennent maintenant une licorne
lui je sais pas où il a trouvé le rayon
chez carrefour
et
et on va pas se mentir regardez la
licorne elle a quand même une drôle de
gueule
nous assure-t-on instagram aller
n'oubliez pas samedi soir pigalle 21h
venez aussi
ce soir cela on s'amusera bilal
et on passe maintenant à neutralité
polémique de la semaine
[Musique]
edwy plenel re bonsoir
ici la boit oui thierry avant de
commencer il ya une question très touchy
qui revient ici au standard est ce qu'on
doit dire et devis comme dans wagons ou
edwy comme dans wapiti on va lui
demander alors edwy edwy plenel rebond
soir vous êtes faut-il le rappeler le co
fondateur et le directeur du site
mediapart le site qui utilise des
méthodes fascistes
xavier bertrand le site au service de la
gauche nicolas sarkozy l'officine des
riches amis de françois hollande
françois fillon le site qui calomnient
jérôme cahuzac
harlem désir le site qui a inventé le
journalisme de buch et bruno roger-petit
qui maintenant travail à l'elysée le
site d'information qui donne envie de
changer de planète alain finkielkraut le
site qui rompt avec la déontologie
journalistique marine le pen le site
vautours qui entretient la maladie de la
transparence hubert védrine au village
sans prétention que les mauvaises
réputations comme démène ou que je reste
coi je passe pour un je ne sais quoi
mais c'est surtout le site seul contre
tous qui a sorti la faire de l'argent
libyen de nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
alors comme pour un jérôme cahuzac à
l'époque de jérôme cahuzac vous alliez
au grand journal et puis la fatigue
d'une longue barbe n'est pas possible on
n'y crois pas pas vrai non non non et
donc vous étiez seul contre tous et là
on regarde donc c'est le scoop du siècle
notre dossier l'argent libyen ne sarkozy
tout la peur sarkozy kadhafi est à
retrouver sur médiapart qui seul l'avait
révélé dès 2011-2012 preuve qu'une
presse indépendante est utile et
nécessaire c'est pas juste un truc a eu
60 enquêtes de mediapart des enquêtes de
fabrice arfi aussi de de karl laske eux
alors dans le livre que vous publiez
chez don quichotte qui s'appelle la
valeur de l'information
vous raconter une histoire de censure
avec le magazine le point à un moment
tout ça est en train de sortir et il ya
une attachée de presse de sarkozy qui
appelle le point et le point appel est
de vie en disant bon nous on va parler y
est le mec dit non tu veux si tu veux le
truc nous non non non non non non c'est
pas un truc nous non non non nous on va
pas en parler c'est ici on n'est pas
médiapart on n'est pas mediapart a
accusé les gens sans preuve enfin tout
pour nous tu sais franchement ça n'a pas
plus d'importance que ça très
franchement nous tu vois on joue pas ces
trucs d'investigation c'est
extraordinaire c'est extra là il faut se
battre même parfois contre d'autres
médias m mais toutes les formules tout à
l'heure c'est trop dommage ouais au fond
nous on est au service du public on
apporte des informations
utiles à tout le monde la sphère cahuzac
l' affaire bettencourt la sphère sarkozy
est évidemment la plus emblématique
parlé il ya une phrase que j'ai mise
dans le livre qui est pour moi très
importante de george orwell le pain de
1984 quand il dit parler de liberté n'a
de sens que si c'est la liberté de dire
aussi aux gens ce qu'ils n'ont pas envie
d'entrer alors nous c'est pas des
opinions c'est faire face à des réalités
l'évasion fiscale la corruption des
politiques savait nicolas sarkozy c'est
une affaire d'une ampleur immense
d'abord ce n'est pas la seule on ne le
rappelle pas assez il est concerné par
trois dossiers judiciaires il est
renvoyé devant un tribunal pour
financement illégal de campagne
électorale dans la sphère bygmalion il
est mis en examen dans la sphère paul
bismuth qui est neil des écoutes
libyenne pour corruption et trafic
d'influencé
et comme vous le savez dans le dossier
libyen corruption passive ça veut dire
que c'est lui qui suscite cette
corruption il n'est pas si passifs
contrairement à ce que voudrait dire
l'expression c'est aussi financement
illégal de campagne électorale c'est pas
celle de 2012 c'est celle de 2007 et
puis recèle recel de détournement de
fonds publics libyens ce qui veut bien
dire que c'est de l'argent qui venait
d'une dictature en somme c'est simple la
dictature libyenne a corrompu une
démocratie la france en contribuant par
son argent à l'élection de celui qui
sera cinq ans président de la république
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que sarko financé par
kadhafi c'est comme le ministre du
budget plantes en pot nyon en suisse au
début ça a l'air d'être des fake news on
se dit c'est pas croyable c'est
impossible qu à usak sarkozy que ça et
alors le gouvernement prépare une loi
sur les fake news vous dit on va tuer la
nouvelle qui dérange le gouvernement
fait une loi d'opportunité une loi de
circonstance et c'est toujours dangereux
par rapport à des libertés fondamentales
de se précipiter comme ça qui est lié à
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis tous
ces moteurs qui balançaient des fausses
nouvelles puisque c'est ce que veut dire
fait que news donc ça ce concerne la
période électorale or il se trouve qu'un
des éléments clés de l'enquète libyenne
on commence nos enquêtes à l'été 2011
notre premier article c'est 28 juillet
2011 et donc qu'on a déjà beaucoup de
documents et finalement on trouve et ça
arrive à ce moment là on le cherche
pendant plusieurs mois on trouve un
document libyen dont personne ne
conteste la verrière et les services
liés par la justice française bien sûr
il faut le dire monsieur sarkozy nous a
poursuivis pour faux et usage de faux je
souligne qu'il ne nous a jamais
poursuivis en diffamation parce qu'ils
seraient les poursuites à la loyale et
on aurait amené nos preuves il a
contourné faux et usage de faux et la
justice nous a donné raison s'est
évidemment je suis directeur publication
de médiapart si je vais en prison que je
publie un faux bon c'est pas ça je ruine
tout ce journal et toutes sont toutes
sous de sa crédibilité et donc ce
document nous l'obtenons nous le
vérifions entre les deux tours de la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 nous
n'avons pas de gestion partisane du
calendrier donc nous sortons quand ces
prêts et dans la loi la loi qui est
prévu il aurait été possible d'une
action en référé -c'est-à-dire immédiat
de 48 heures c'est beau ça va influencer
voilà un sucre brut 1 il faut taire
cette nouvelle il faut l'étouffer alors
la ministre de la culture entend ce que
je dis est ce que nous disons et elle
dit mais il faudra des conditions que ce
soit repris dans des robots etc mais
quand vous sortez que le président
clients je rappelle ce que dit le
document 1 c'est un document
bureaucratique libyen fin 2006 qui dit
qu'ils s'engagent à financer à hauteur
de 50 millions d'euros la campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy et
donc c'est énorme sarkozy lui il dit que
tout ça c'est des mensonges est ce que
c'est une défense qui va pouvoir tenir
longtemps
le débat il est pas entre mediapart et
sarkozy il est devant les juges c'est
autrement sérieux et les juges ils n'ont
pas des mensonges ils ont toutes sortes
d'éléments recouper je vais vous donner
un exemple quand on sort notre
révélations de 2012 le lendemain le 29
avril 2012 à vienne à vienne en autriche
on retrouve noyé dans le danube l'ancien
ministre du pétrole libyen s'appelle
chokri ghanem et qu'est-ce qu'on a
retrouvé comme par hasard on a retrouvé
après dans les carnets de ce monsieur
des notes de 2007 faisant état d'une
réunion organisant le versement de
l'argent au clan sarkozy un million cinq
par la 20 millions la 2 millions au
total on sait qu'à lui dizaines de
millions qui ont à peu près été versée
mais il y à beaucoup d'autres éléments
dans ce dossier il y a par exemple
abdallah senoussi le chef des services
secrets libyens il était condamné à la
réclusion à perpétuité par la france
pourquoi pour l'attentât contre le dc10
d'uta 170 morts et bien dans le dossier
il ya qu'entre 2005 et 2007 monsieur
sarkozy rend compte ce monsieur dans une
chambre d'hôtel et ce monsieur demande
via l'avocat de monsieur sarkozy qu'on
arrange son dossier judiciaire
bien sûr tout le monde a le droit de se
défendre tout le monde est présumé
innocent quand on est devant la justice
et la procédure est fait pour protéger y
compris les délinquants monsieur sarkozy
a tous les droits en tant que
justiciable de se défendre mais nous
journalistes on n'est pas juge on n'est
pas magistrat on ne met pas des soupçons
sur la table on met des faits et l'essai
sont désormais là je le redis nous
n'avons subi aucune poursuite en
diffamation 60 articles un livre de
fabrice arfi karl laske eu aucune
poursuite
alors
ces juges tournaire là parce qu'on nous
le dise à un pur et dur tout ça c'est
être vie plein air de la magistrature
est-ce qu'il est contre sarko est ce
qu'il en veut à sarko parce que sarko
dit mon voeu il fait son travail d'abord
ils sont trois juges oui ils sont trois
juges lui est le plus connu ils sont
trois juges mais je voudrais souligner
une chose qui alerté sur l'état de notre
démocratie
il ya une enquête aux états unis
ingérence et la russie dans un processus
électoral procureur spécial 60
enquêteurs la sphère libyenne révélé il
y a bientôt 7 ans
mediapart ouverture de l'information
judiciaire il ya 5 en 2013 il ya combien
de policiers un seul arrêt un seul et il
n'est même pas à plein temps ils sont
pressés vers d'autres dossiers seront
pas prêts c'est ça l'état de la justice
anti corruption en france c'est ça sa
lenteur savait il a fallu la faire
cahuzac les révélations l'effet de
souffle de mediapart tient pendant
quatre mois on est tout seul et tout
finalement le ministre du budget est un
fraudeur fiscal et et met son argent
dans des paradis fiscaux pourquoi pour
la création du parc et financier qui
n'existait pas avant ici je vois oui
thierry j'ai ici à l'accueil une
douzaine de costauds en imperméable qui
demande à voir edwy plenel que ce que je
leur dis
sarkozy en garde-à-vue sarkozy mis en
examen quel beau cadeau d'anniversaire
pour les 10 ans de médiapart vers là on
voit le buffet voilà c'est là le premier
gâteau qui a été offert aux invités
le deuxième gâteau voilà bon mais c'est
vrai qu'on a eu le tort de trop parler
de moustache noire il tout ce qui se
passe je le regrette un peu j'avais
retrouvé des photos de vous bébé voilà
le travail
qu'est ce que tu veux
sarkozy mme sarkozy m'a cassé mon cou
alors médiapart à 10 ans 140 mille
abonnés 4 7 millions de visiteurs tous
les mois 2,2 millions de résultat ce qui
est énorme et c'est vrai qu'avec vous
les gens découvrent que finalement le
journalisme c'est pas seulement de poser
des questions sur l'arbre de noël de
l'elysée à emmanuel macron pense
évidemment à laurent delahousse qui a
dit voici le sapin de noël dans la cour
de l'elysée c'est la fin de l'année que
voulez-vous dire aux français monsieur
le président c'est vrai que ça c'est du
journalisme je crois que c'est
indépassable médiapart nous notre seul
critère c'est simple on peut on peut ne
pas nous aimer ou ne pas aimer telle
prise de position tel débat sur
mediapart mais pour moi il ya un seul
critère cité mois en dix ans en dix ans
une seule information qu'on est publié
et qu'ils se soient affairés à la foux
fosse est inutile dans le débat public
je crois qu'il y en a pas y'en a pas
médiapart se porte très bien je me
souviens dans la main
ce grand conseiller du cac 40
prédisant que ça n'avait pas marché en
rien
la presse sur le net ne peut être que
gratuite la presse payante sur le net ne
peut pas marcher et voilà bravo et avec
patrons du cac 40
qui paye à la main il des fortunes pour
avoir ses conseils 1 c'est ici rêve oui
ce n'est pas parce que arnaud ducret est
parmi nous que mediapart ne doit pas
parler de ces magouilles fiscale
alors maintenant quand même les choses
qui fâchent un peu et kamina info vous
n'aviez pas c'est le passé de tariq
ramadan mais personne n'avait trouvé moi
un article qui a été publié avant notre
grande enquête de cinq volets qui était
une enquête impitoyable qui a beaucoup
déplu à tariq ramadan tous les mois un
article qui est fait état des délits
comment ça peut vous ont cherché nous
attentions nous on publie pas de fausses
nouvelles donc c'est pas un bruit dans
une rédaction on dit que monsieur machin
truc et que certains font que ce soit
vrai il faut que ce soit recouper et
surtout dans ces affaires là attention
dans ces affaires-là ça peut pas être un
témoignage non il faut plus se recoupent
et ça met en cause une autre unité
produit quatre vies le figaro magazine
vous a traité
d'agents d' influence de l'islam en
france
ouais on va en parler c'est la bataille
des idées du chapitre bègue
j'en ai fait
[Musique]
et voilà c'est le consultant en
géopolitique
alexandre del vals que nous retrouverons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto battle
de ce soir que se cache-t-il derrière l'
islam is
[Musique]
en 2015 les assassins de charlie hebdo
ont revendiqué leurs crimes au nom
d'allah
mais la mosquée al azhar en egypte l'une
des plus hautes autorités qui slame a
tout de suite pris ses distances ces
actes n'ont rien à voir avec l'islam ni
avec la réalité de la religion islamique
en laquelle nous croyons dans son livre
alexandre delval souligne que ce n'est
pas tout à fait vrai le grand imam de la
mosquée larmette el-tayeb est considéré
comme le musulmans le plus influent du
monde or s'il a déjà excommunie des
intellectuels critiquer l'islam en
revanche il a toujours refusé d'exprimer
les djihadistes de dèche le problème
c'est que certains passages du coran
justifie la mort des infidèles et comme
le coran c'est la parole de dieu
impossible de s'y opposer pourtant après
chaque attentat c'est toujours la même
rengaine à londres l'an dernier le chef
de la police a même lu un message rédigé
par la communauté musulmane c'est donc
un message de la communauté musulmane à
la suite de l'attentât de longbridge
cette attaque terroriste est une attaque
contre toutes les communautés et aussi
la communauté musulmane résultat alors
que les occidentaux sont victimes des
djihadistes mais voilà accusé
d'islamophobie
du coup le gouvernement français se sent
obligé financer des clips contre les
actes anti-musulmans moi tous ces
musulmans ça me fait peur on en voit
partout scénario mais si on fait rien
dans vingt ans la france sera musulmane
les actes anti musulmans ça commence par
des mots tous unis contre hollande
tandis que la france joue l'apaisement
certains pays musulmans sont très
conquérant l'an dernier le président
erdogan a carrément demandé aux émigrés
turcs de faire le plus d'enfants
possibles pour conquérir l'europe
je rappelle à mes concitoyens mes frères
et soeurs qui vivent en europe cet
endroit où vous vivez vous travaillez
est désormais votre patrie fait xix
votre place et surtout ne fait pas trois
mais cinq enfants cette semaine 100
intellectuels ont publié une tribune
dans le figaro pour dénoncer l'islamisme
qui cherchent à isoler les musulmans du
reste de la société de fait les
islamistes ont déjà gagné une bataille
puisque selon un sondage ifop pour le
très sérieux institut montaigne 28% des
français musulmans placent l'islam au
dessus des lois de la république voilà
cette hérédité de draco milan l'image de
julien gracq alléchante delval bonsoir
il est consultant en géopolitique
professeur khalid al et notre dernier la
stratégie de l'intimidation est paru aux
éditions de l'artilleur bienvenue dans
king mardi dans le figaro 100
intellectuels dont luc ferry bernard
kouchner pascal bruckner boualem sansal
ont signé un appel contre le séparatisme
islamistes il dénonce la montée en
france d'un islamisme qui ne dit pas son
nom sous couvert de lutte contre
l'islamophobie et sous couvert de
stratégie de victimisation il accuse
l'islamisme de créer un éclatement
communautaire somme toute un apartheid
c'est exactement ce que vous racontez
dans le clip de cette tribune je les lui
elle est très intéressante elle reprend
d'ailleurs mon expression le
totalitarisme islamiste que j'avais
lancé dans les années 90 est et je suis
pas le seul d'autres l'ont fait avant
moi donc vous voyez rien de nous lorsque
j'ai quitté votre position à nous
inviter les spectateurs pour vous les
terroristes djihadistes ne sont pas des
hérétiques marginaux mais le bras armé
d'une révolution islamiste qui veut
soumettre le monde sait bien c'est bien
ce que vous dites un c'est donc ce
serait bien de faire la guerre contre
d'âge il faut la faire contre
l'islamisme institutionnel c'est mieux
résumer que que ce que j'écris moi même
mais effectivement toutes ces guerres
impérialistes toutes ces guerres en irak
ou même sept cette volonté au départ de
renverser un autre état souverain bachar
al-assad tout c'est tout c'est tout cet
impérialisme et cet interventionnisme
occidental ne sert à rien parce que
quand on lit les textes des djihadistes
qu'est ce qu'ils demandent ils demandent
justement que l'ennemi lointain viennent
les bombarder chez eux ils se
nourrissent de ce genre d'opération
avant d'exporter des valeurs d'ailleurs
que nous trahissons très souvent dans
ces pays par des guerres par des
parrains d'interventionnisme je pense
que nos dirigeants seraient plutôt
fondées à défendre ses valeurs chez nous
dans nos banlieues où il y à des prières
de rue qui sont organisées par des
organisations islamistes comme je dis
dans mon livre qui cherche à intimider
alors par la violence par le meur par
les menaces par la culpabilisation il ya
les coupeurs de langue d'un côté ce qui
nous empêche de parler et les coupeurs
de tête c'est les djihadistes j'affirme
qu'il son complice parce que dans ce
livre analyse tous les pôles de
l'islamisme aucun officiel interne du
jeu maintenant justement mon cher alex
ans ma bande de laisser la parole à être
dix plaies j'aurais parlé effectivement
du plus grand lobby théocratique
mondiale vite vous l'organisation de la
coopération islamique qui regroupe quand
même 57 pays avec un objectif c'est de
contrôler dit vous les communautés
musulmanes d'éviter une d islamisation
et ensuite d'utiliser ces communautés
comme vecteurs de la propagation de
l'islam rigoriste toujours dans le soft
power vous parlez de la ligue islamiste
mondial trois mille mètres carrés à
mantes-la-jolie dans les yvelines vous
parlez de 75 milliards pour promouvoir
le salafisme dans le monde et puis il ya
d'autres choses dans votre livre mais
disons ça me suffit pour demander un
rapport à cette idée que finalement
au-delà des djihadistes au delà des
attentes at it bataclan il ya une espèce
de volonté mondial
organisé financé pour soumettre les
populations occidentales qu'un peu
l'idée doit le bec dans soumission vous
réagissez comme ans pour vous c'est de
la parano
tout dépend si vous parlez de certains
pays ou si vous parlez de notre pays il
ya un pays qui s'appelle l'arabie
saoudite que nous finançons auquel nous
vendons des armes qui est le foyer
idéologique de cette vision totalitaire
de l'islam c'est l'allié de nos
gouvernants monsieur l'andi a été trente
six fois et
l'association l'arcade qui est les
chrétiens contre la torture mène une
action class actionne comme on dit sur
le fait que la guerre sale guerre du
yémen et fait avec nos armes et là
évidemment c'est une monarchie absolue
et c'est une vision totalement
absolutiste de la religion contre les
libertés individuelles
en revance là où évidemment je me sais
pas ça fait 30 ans que de ces menaces de
ces attentats de ses peurs certains le
traduisent pour nous dresser les uns
contre les autres ici et moi je suis
contre ça je dis une chose toute simple
ahmed mera bête le policier qui sacrifie
sa vie au bas du charlie hebdo il est
musulman pratiquant et c'est un policier
de la république française lassana
batelli qui sauve les otages à l'hyper
cacher il est arrivé sans papiers il
vient du mali et il est musulman aussi
les musulmans y compris au bataclan son
taux dans les terrasses noah nice nos
compatriotes et on va nous dire
attention le vrai danger c'est le
musulman lacs et autres et de vous et ça
je suis content et je suis au pas ce
qu'on dit mais c'est ce que beaucoup
beaucoup les musulmans moi je parle d'un
totalitarisme bouzigues l'islam sunnite
l'islam n'ont absolument pas je parle
d'un disque en attendant exemple je
correction à morteau de l'espace et de
la qualité de vie que le mec est en bas
de charlie hebdo c'est un musulman il se
fait dézinguer comme les jours mais
c'est bataclan chez le musulman je
m'excuse je me prends des balles comme
les autres jamais d'accord avec on
rentre dans la stratégie d'intimidation
que je décris dans mon livre pourquoi se
justifie mais c'est évident vous et moi
et vous sur ce plateau personne n'a
envie de 2,2 d'agresser des musulmans
auraient dû lycée que les gens fassent
l'amalgamé
personne n'empêche les musulmans d'être
musulmans en france et un mythe
l'islamophobie est une arme qui permet
de rétablir le délit de blasphème ce que
je dis c'est que les pôles de
l'islamisme international l'arabie
saoudite et les lieux saints c'est pas
n'importe quoi el azhar en egypte c'est
la plus grande université université
sunnite l'épaule de l'islamisme qui ont
pignon sur rue chez nous on pourrait
rajouter aussi erdogan le néo ottoman
erdogan qui veut rétablir le califat en
2024 cet homme aussi à amy le mari de sa
cousine à la tête de l'islam de france
est ce que c'est normal que l'islam de
france et comme chef aujourd'hui à
remettre aux grasses qui est un militant
historique d'erdogan d'année aux
ottomans totalitaire qui veut or qui a
un projet de doc et avec ce géant des
musulmans de france mérite mieux vous
pouvez que quelqu'un du longuet a fait
ça fait 20 ans que monsieur delval ne
fait qu'une obsession est déjà en
possession il n'a qu'un sujet au niveau
le trouvais rémois à monsieur erdogan
moi mais moi écouter jouer mais attendez
je pars et a toujours refusé - l'actu
ciné aux automates vous paraissez frais
sans moi je parraine turkana au gluten
journalistes
journalistes d'investigation youtube
fait un allin désigné vous-même gérons
vous et vous ne m'interrompez je vous
réponds c'est la plus grande prison de
journalistes aujourd'hui la turquie et
la france l'europe lui donne plein
d'argent pour bloquer ce qu'on devrait
accueillir les demandeurs de refuge le
problème n'est pas laid ce que je vous
exprimer assimiler les musulmans
allaient se mérite et perez lass genève
a indiqué les musées on a le droit
revenons au débat et non mais laissez
moi le plus nos noms voudrait non vous
faites un amalgame et à domicile sad
étrangères avec 150 euros sur le modèle
du genre ou ne pouvait pas dire si vous
ne pouvez pas dire les jeux éthique
grave et je n'aime pas disons si les je
n'ai pas dis ça je dis juste qu'il ya
des gens dont vous êtes qui depuis 20
ans n'ont qu'un agenda la question de
l'égalité la question des droits des
femmes la question du chômage se pose la
question des libertés mais oui c'est pas
l'heure ce genre le sujet jamais leur
sujet de famille n'ont qu'un seul sujet
dire vous n'avez qu'un problème c'est
l'islam vous n'avez qu'un problème c'est
les musulmans ils n'ont que celui là il
ya un seul des musiciens là on ne s'en
plaint des musées elle raille de lier la
mise mon accord vous mélangez tout est
possible et continuer fait là étudiés
abidjan est une chose qui m'a très
intéressante d'abord sur les musulmans
qui sont qui sont assassinés c'est un
très bon argument parce que les nazis
ils ont tué aussi beaucoup d'allemands
mais moi ce que je sais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que je ne dirais pas les
noms je connais d'humoristes musulmans
et musulmanes qui m'a nantes dès
qu'elles font un sketch si elles vont un
peu trop loin on est mené à fabas oui et
c'est pas tous les musulmans gâcher
alors comment vous faites mais il ya de
la viande rouge organes ou les inconnus
costa gavras et l'asthme et yann mama
fameux dejiang au mieux pas mais il ya
cette il ya une bataille les nazis ont
tué beaucoup d'amour c'est ça le
problème mais c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des musulmans bien évidemment ne
veulent pas le gars n'est rien mais il
faut se méfier de ça il ya une bataille
à mener contre l'intolérance par tout ce
que je voulais dire pourquoi je parlais
je disais pas y tue aussi des musulmans
ou sens c'est de dire attention
l'origine ne protège de rien dans tout
ça est que y compris on le voit vu dans
les terroristes il ya des convertis un
donc voilà
est assez inquiétant ou dit médiapart
est devenu un instrument de propagande
frérot salafistes
antilaïque et antirépublicaine
edwy plenel épouse la stratégie de
l'islam politique bon c'est un collabo
ses eaux elle collabore je cite
l'article du figaro en effet je pense
qu'effectivement ce qui facilite
l'islamisme sont l'équivalent de ce qui
facilite d'autres totalitarisme donc
c'est une forme de collaboration au sens
étymologique du terme et d'ailleurs ce
qu'il a dit tout à l'heure que moi je
parle des pôles de l'islamisme mondiale
et que on accuse le stigmatiser les
musulmans c'est l'illustration parfaite
de la stratégie de l'intimidation des
coupeurs de langues ce que c'est que
c'est lorsque le rouge est de le vert
savait que beaucoup d'anciens
trotskistes et d'anciens militants
d'extrême gauche voit dans l'islamisme
une sorte de prolétariat une armée de
substitution qui va être un bélier
faites vous entre la république vous
plaisir et bien je m'en prive pas que
j'aime chez monsieur me donne
actuellement ça m'arrange qu'ils soient
là il illustra pas par son vécu parce
qu'ils emploient comme terminologie il
illustre parfaitement la stratégie de
l'intimidation j'appelle le nos
auditeurs à lire ce livre ils vont voir
la
logique illange appelle monsieur del
valle bien d'autres est allié aux
mediapart matthieu suc les meilleures
enquêtes respecté par tous les services
de renseignements sur le terrorisme sur
sa communication sur les services de
renseignements mais pas auto promotion
il est bon vous roulez trouvez vous les
trouverez sur mediapart simplement
encore une fois nous comme journal nous
nous revendiquons des principes des
droits de l'homme nous ne sommes pas du
côté de deux lits dans ce cadre à vos
promotions vous avez un croit dur comme
fer clause de l'identique vous êtes un
roi de l'identité fermé nous sommes pour
voilà des relations dans le respect de
chacun et moi moi moi je je suis
l'incarnation de l'identité ouvert champ
d'honneur d'avoir été avec nous ben
c'est la peur celle des autres après la
pub un coup dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
demain soir est un ami jeanne de retour
sur terre toujours en compagnie de
victoria abril
2 tiens mon dont
arnaud ducret et de lombalgie
et on passe maintenant à notre invité
culte de la semaine
[Musique]
c'est toi c'était
à
[Musique]
victoria abril bonsoir
alors comment savoir quel est des deux
affaires à arnaud parce qu'elle a déjà
beaucoup parlé
à temps car non à la vengeance après
logique alors j'adore votre accent c'est
un accent extraordinaire vous pouvez
prendre n'importe quel mot du
dictionnaire et le rendre sexy et langue
aux dites moi par exemple imodium malien
voilà même imodium
40 ans vous êtes en france n'ait pas
progressé vous faites exprès qu'il n'est
pas pressé
alors dit moi est ce que tu as gardé cet
accent parce que tu as peur qu'on te
reconnaissent plus après 30 ans de vie
en france ça ne sert à rien et vous
garde par les français comme 60 millions
dé france oui c'est vrai tu restes
victoria abril et tomac soir toi comme
ça il y en a pas beaucoup de lacunes il
a vaincu ses mémoires oui acheter vos
choix de rejoindre que j'ai pris mon
petit âge
on est énervé vraiment dans tous les cas
vous remettez en cause tout le système
éducatif d'apprentissage des langues par
l'immersion dans un pays non est le
problème c'est qu'une langue situe la
plante pas avant les dix ans tu garderas
l'accent a visité ce vrai arrêtons de
faire un château en espagne
il faut
alors au sujet du mouvement balance tant
powers a déclaré personne ne m'a jamais
demandé de passer par une chambre pour
faire un film je commence à me demander
pourquoi
bah oui marie parce qu'elle compte dans
les bureaux c'est
quand même moi aussi parce que regarder
ses photos quoi ah oui oui oui ça c'est
cannes et bonita rêverie moins beau mais
tu sais c'est l'année où il n'y avait
pas le politiquement correct
rigaudiat en espagne alors je ne vais
pas tellement harcelée par les
producteurs via mais c'est bizarre comme
jamais jamais après le mouvement moi
aussi qu'il défend les femmes harcelées
ont dit vous avez lancé le mouvement et
moi pour celle qui monte
[Rires]
celles qui n'ont pas encore été harcelés
non je voulais quand même rempli une
lance pour les hommes on va pas mettre
maintenant tous les on va pas faire des
amalgames a condamné oui
essentialiser comme dirait louis plenel
c'est à dire 8 les hommes ne sont pas
tous des ports ça va trop loin il y à un
juste milieu à trouver
qu'est-ce qu'on serait sans eux marc
valat qu'est-ce qu'on serait sans vous
rien avant l'heure
[Applaudissements]
alors en victoria retrouver l'époque
beaucoup trop politiquement correct vous
dites on est une époque des ministres
qui démissionne pour un tweet c'est bien
mais ça fout c'est vrai rêver c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux ont
pris le pouvoir on peut plus rien dire
vous n'êtes pas réseaux sociaux non non
j'aimerais fusent des vivres à travers
un
téléphone au lieu des vivres en raison
la vie où j'ai pas le temps j'ai
d'autres chats à fouetter et puis et
puis j'ai passé ma vie du passé plus de
trente ans a justement caché l'endroit
de mes vacances
décret on ne peut occulter des
mystérieux qu'est ce que ça veut dire là
maintenant je m'élève j'aimais coup je
mange sagem
elle a parfaitement raison vous étiez un
truc très intelligent vous dit quand on
est quelque part il vaut mieux regarder
quand photographier je trouve que vous
avez parfaitement raison
alors nous y sommes vous êtes ici ce
soir pour paprika donc la nouvelle pièce
de pierre palmade au théâtre de la
madeleine alors le pitch est var c'est à
dire vous et la présentatrice d'une
revue de strip tease à pigalle
et d'hommes ainsi voilà elle enchaîne
les conquêtes c'est une croqueuse
d'hommes 1 c'est une hélas un matin
débarque chez elle un dénommé l'udc qui
est joué par jean baptiste maunier qu'un
garçon il ya 28 ans donc il frappe à la
porte et il dit je suis ton fils voilà
et souliers les fils des vins fromages
et lenny vous dites je suis paprika donc
la femme de ménage et je dois dire vous
êtes assez formidable dans le rôle là
remerciements nombreux membres ait aidé
d'un
fils toi et puis 28 ans depuis 20
minutes je ne sais pas
ces jeunes au bénéfice des bas mais
quand moi je suis pas pris qu'un la
femme de ménage irles yens
ou et clémentine gc c'est une épice sait
pas plus cons que d'avoir un prénom de
fille était
signalé que femme de ménage avec des
femmes de ménage les médecins ont bien
des médecins
il faut bien que guy kassa jamais lâché
moi pendant obliger les cas ici non mais
tu réfléchis des poids
des coûts vous parlez d qui
kiffe les
guetta fait les élèves de ma mère allait
bien ce n'est plus de mon ressort
elle apporte rien de bien emballant
arbres et c'est en direct sur france 2
le mardi à douala larbins sentir pourra
le voir cette pièce qui finit les 21
avril c'est vachement bien
alors il ya quelqu'un qui est très bien
aussi c'est jean baptiste maunier donc
qui est le héros des choristes oui c'est
qu'au vatican c'est considéré comme un
film érotique les choristes ah bon
alors évidemment le personnage est très
proche de vous en fait la fille qui boit
qui se tape des petits jeunes n'ont
personne à dents ça s'est passé pas loin
mais sinon si cette femme sera simple à
moi c'est parce qu'elle n'a ni violent
ni amant ouais ni dieu ni maître avec un
pacs est monté sur scène sans
1986 voilà avec vives réactions your
qu'ensuite il ya eu les filiales des
enfants j'ai fait de théâtre on est
heureux de vous revoir aux tablettes
vraiment vous brûler les planches
comment dire je voulais dire si les plus
grandes actrices françaises et
espagnoles franchement que ce soit dans
le gazon maudit salsigne et oui
étrangères aussi ben oui parce qu'on
parlait des actions tout à l'heure c'est
très très rare de jouer aussi dans une
langue qui n'est pas la sienne au départ
en plus ce charme ce mystère
et j'étais pas sur instagram elle était
à la pointe au soleil
non en fait victoria que ce soit pour
chanter si vous avez fait aussi des
disques des pins et des concerts sur
scène où que ce soit pour jouer la
comédie vous adorez la scène vous dites
oui je me prépare toute la journée pour
mon rendez vous amoureux de 21h ça vous
a préparé la nom
et
y avait tellement normalement que moi
j'aime élève à 2 heures et l'après midi
je prends mon petit déjeuner j'ai
préparé ma baignoire et puis après voilà
j'aime effet belge et médium effet bel
et gbého au théâtre g prendre des airs
au théâtre pour me maquiller comme si
j'allais mais ma vie c'est comme si je
me mariais tous les soirs c'est ça et
c'est pour ça que je signale excellente
sur scène parce qu'effectivement il ya
toute cette énergie alors vous avez joué
paprika seulement pendant trois mois
voilà à cause de clem la série de tf1 on
est quand même loin de pedro almodovar
oui ça n'a rien à voir puisque vous avez
déclaré pedro almodovar n'est pas mort
mais apparemment je le suis pour lui
annoncer parce qu'à chaque fois on me
demande pour lui et j'ai dû dire non
mais moi pour pedro j suis déçu il est
morte depuis vingt cinq ans que ça
n'arrive pas fâché non parce qu'on a
beaucoup vu avec penelope cruz cela
quand même bah oui parce qu'il a
toujours des mises dans les années 80
c'était calme et maura dans les années
90 c'était moi dans les années 2000
c'était penelope il a toujours une muse
des trente ans c'est son truc et maman
claire la question sous serment
[Musique]
ça fait peur et vous avez raison d'avoir
peur ouais c'est ce qui est arrivé à
nicolas sarkozy cette semaine
alors victoria abril vous avez quitté
l'espagne par amour c'est au début des
années 80 si c'était à refaire est ce
que vous le referiez bien sûr vous
regrettez pas d'avoir quitté l'espagne
pour venir en france non je suis qui
j'ai quitté l'espagne pour venir vivre
mon histoire d'amour en france et il n'y
a que l'amour depuis toutes ces années
qui m'est fait bouger qui m'est fait et
mais réveillez qui me donne des forces
vous le jurer de l'hégire aura lui même
l'a juré
[Musique]
tomassi
bien merci avec un des pions je vous
demande de partir parce que vous êtes
chauds scène ce soir
[Applaudissements]
les crocs et partagera à
et on passe maintenant notre terriens du
samedi soir
[Musique]
jill craybas ce bon choix
a largué à l'âge de 19 ans après avoir
fui le cuba de fidel castro vous
débarquez en france où vous allez
bientôt devenir le disquaire le plus
branché de paris la musique du palace
c'est vous ensuite ce seront les affres
de la solitude et les ténèbres de la
cécité mais aujourd'hui vous revenez
pour nous raconter une époque bénie
et
or comme ans guillermo crievat scarione
absolue vous êtes né le 29 août 1945 à
la havane à cuba à l'époque le dictateur
batista est encore au pouvoir votre père
est mécanicien dans votre père c'était
quand même un match au taciturne un très
beau oui ils avaient les traits indien
et votre mère était blanche oui elle
avait elle-même une mère française et
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement élégant et
raffiné
à la maison on parle pas beaucoup et
tout on écoute la radio on écoute du
tango on écoute de la bossa nova en
écoute des opérettes ce qui fait qu
effectivement vous êtes formé très jeune
à la musique enfants vous êtes très
solitaire vous jouer aux dames dans
votre coin vous aviez peur des autres un
peu oui oui du regard des autres une
façon innée je crois que je tenais pour
être seul je m'intéressais à autre chose
qui l'intéressait pas le petit gars m'a
demandé mon âge et à l'école vous avez
des bonnes notes mais vous vous levez
mélangez pas aux autres vous préférez la
compagnie de votre maman vous dire
j'étais le mari de ma mère un jour
je jouerai jupe de haute mer ça
m'arrangerait bien à la autre centre
d'intérêt glisser la littérature des
rares cultures très très jeune vous
commencé à écrire des nouvelles puis
vous passionner pour chagall vous
passionner pour soutine vous voyez les
films de la nouvelle vague
d'ailleurs à cuba vous croisé agnès
varda vanessa grève et son mari tony
richardson au delà enseignèrent très
jeune j'avais été quand même attiré par
la culture quand par une dimension
culturelle de la ville en 1970 15 ans et
vous suivez les cours d'un atelier de
dramaturgie vous fondez avec des amis
maison d'édition vous publier des
nouvelles
et vous découvrez edith piaf à l'époque
alors que la plupart de vos amis rêve
des états unis rêve de new york vous
rêvez de paris ce que je vois le film
exprès à la havane qui n'est projeté que
tout ce film-là hiroshima mon amour les
amants jeanne moreau et c'est tout c'est
paris
tous les premiers films de truffaut et
les otc paris gris où tout est gris les
parapluies noirs tout ça va arriver
pluie de coups noyés alors sexuellement
vous êtes homosexuel et vous brisez pas
beaucoup en fait vous avez tous non je
me sentais coupable en plus j'habite et
à une même ma mère mon père me dit et je
ne l'écoutais jamais en plus si en
arrivant à paris on va voir ça plus tard
que là on n'en vend pas mais je suis
venu tout perrin surtout
alors qu à l'époque personne ne regrette
le dictateur batista parce que batista
c'était la corruption la prostitution
les casinos donc quand castro arrive
évidemment personne ne regrette ce
dictateur inféodés aux gringos américain
au début tout le monde adore castro mais
les choses se gâtent vraiment la peine
de mort est rétabli il ya des
prisonniers politiques
elle est traître entre guillemets sont
fuselés action c'est un waf fusillé à la
télé à la whey des gens condamnés à
faire on attendait leur pouvoir les gens
qui ont les guerriers à la télé ah oui
c'est énorme voilà puis aussi il faut le
dire des rafles d'homosexuels qui
commence à travers voilà et là vous
décidez donc de quitter cuba vous voulez
devenir ce qu'on appelle c'est très
péjoratif à l'époque on appelle ça un
goût sano c'est à dire une larve car les
gens qui quittaient le régime castriste
étaient traités de l'arve mais ça me
gêne pas vous avez quand j'ai envie de
partir et là miracle
vous rencontrer fidel castro chez sa
maîtresse margarita une actrice
uruguayenne et la scène extraordinaire
si vous êtes chez margarita castro
arrive avec un jambon dans un torchon
quand même un cadeau de noël pour elle
et il arrivait dont vous lui parlez vous
lui dites voilà j'aimerai bien voyager
et il vous dit appelle incarne ita elle
va s'occuper de toi est en fait vous
vous avez un cousin qui bosse à l'unesco
à paris qu'est prêt non pas vous
accueillir mais ils ont à faciliter
votre voyage et castro accepte que vous
partiez à paris ce kon extraordinaire et
donc début janvier
1964 vous envoler vers l'europe et vous
arrivez à paris votre cousin qui possède
unesco socrates socrates alors socrates
il est pas super sympa parce qu'il vous
fait poireauter quatre heures dans le
bistrot boulevard gouvion saint cyr a
conclu absolument battre sherwin il vous
fait même pas monté chez lui ce qu'en
dit tout un quel connard
et en plus il vous amène non pas chez
lui mais dans un hôtel minable minable
où il a payé la nuit m'a laissé tout
seul avec tous mes doutes avaient lieu
regrettait déjà presque plat vous à la
piscine à voir oui oui rien de très
important je voudrais juste dire à guy
oui c'est normal qu'ils ne me vois pas
oui oui à lui demander pourquoi il imite
l'accent de victoria abril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors à l'époque vous portez votre
misère avec nestor almendros c'était la
plus chic et on était dans la merde tous
les deux d'accord vous vous deviendrez
ce que vous êtes devenu mais lui
deviendra le directeur photo de truffaut
de 'rumeurs de barbet schroeder car
marion évidemment c'est un type
extraordinaire et l'or pour survivre à
l'est pas ou fait des petits boulots
d'être agent de voyages êtes
manutentionnaire au printemps vous
passez l'aspirateur au bhv sanaa alors
tout va changer lorsque vous rencontrez
c'est vérossaz réduit donc qu'il était
éditeur aux éditions du seuil et y vous
trouvez un job vous mettez les livres
dans les cartons aux éditions du seuil
pour les hauts revenus aux libraires
voilà c'est votre premier boulot dans
l'édition ap st et là vous rencontrez
grâce à céder au sort des rencontres et
roland barthes que vous faites marrer
quoi parce que je n'ai pas très timide
roland bas et vous vous lui faites des
vannes libertines
j'adore mais c'est un dénommé henri
guaino le disquaire d'une boîte qui
s'appelait le fiacre qu'il va vous
brancher dans le métier de dj de
disquaires comme on disait à l'époque
et là vous fréquentez le nuage est alors
au début des années 70 vous devenez le
boute en train du nuage vous commencé à
rencontrer des gens vont au lider
massimo gargia ouais
et puis karl lagarfeld et puis kenzo etc
et alors vous vous créez votre style on
peut dire que quand vous passez aux
platines vous commencez à imposer le
style très vaste c'est à dire que vous
mélangez tout vous mélangez aussi bien
du rock de l'opérette que dès que des
bruits avec des effets sonores bouclé le
style cuevas à ce moment là et le nuage
appartenait à gérald nanty qu'on a tous
connu dans un matisse
des années plus tard et dont on salue la
mémoire
et après gérald nanty donc c'est fabrice
nerfs vous êtes remarqué quand même par
toutes les stars de la nuit parisienne
c'est fabrice et mer qui vous remarque
et vous devenez dj d'une boîte mémorable
rue sainte-anne qui s'appelle le set est
une boîte tout petit mais où il y avait
tout le monde là vous croisez françoise
sagan jeanne moreau robert hirsch
francis bacon saint laurent et bergé et
francis bacon était quand même
bien allumé quand contre l'alcool et la
cocaïne il était comme le tout comme la
peinture ou ses peintures les tirs est
amochée points de suture
et piggy c'est aussi l'époque des top
models oui c'est à dire qu'à l'époque
avec la lotus était plus belle fille du
monde tout est le 1er mars 1978 il y à
40 ans fabrice et maire ouvre le palace
il est pourquoi je vois la vie
alors je vais dire à stéphane guillon je
n'ai pas les larmes aux yeux
sur commande connard gélard mesure parce
que je suis ému tu verras un jour ça
peut arriver d'être ému tu verras
alors au palace la terre entière s'y
bousculent évidemment karl lagerfeld est
un nom
commercial enzo mick jagger andy warhol
et ce sont vraiment les dernières fait
que paris a connu parce que depuis
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
de grandes fêtes à paris on regarde le
palace
[Musique]
allez
c'est le dernier blizzard qu'en voyant
ces images ça te procure aucune émotion
en 1982 la fête tire à sa fin
fabrice et mère est malade et non pas du
sida contrairement à ce que tout le
monde raconte mais d'un cancer de la
vessie il commence à prendre de la coke
soul influence d'un amant à lui il est
ruiné et arrive le sida la fête est
finie
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est pas plus loin
et voilà c'est la fin de l'insouciance
oui la fin du libertinage vous partez du
palace guy sur un coup de tête oui sans
fil des minutes et non parce que je
pense et plus je connaissais même pas
s'acheter un petit minutes émigrés
ensuite vous vous retrouver au banc de
touche alors effectivement c'est tout à
fait différent c'est patron du banc de
touche à l'époque c'est pas fabrice et
mer mais bon c'est quand même encore une
bonne époque vous croiser robert de niro
jack nicholson arme à l'épaule ans qu'il
navigue ensuite on était très sympa vous
y resterez jusqu'en 1990 et c'est là que
nous tournerons ban minuit
ensemble où chaque semaine voici une
séquence qui s'appelait le chou gras
c'est bien et vous nous disiez les
disques qu'il fallait écouter cd chaque
semaine on regarde
sochaux la semaine alors qu'est ce que
c'est
chez habitat des médecins de pierre
d'albi ouais c'est quelqu'un dont on
parlera beaucoup quand susan et gaby
comme halak a eu droit exceptionnel
c'est très chouette
je souhaite qu'on pourra comparer avec
des pertes heures le lendemain il habite
en angleterre il habite alors éteint le
numéro
c'est et les bains douches c'était bain
de minuit
c'était ma première émission de
télévision ensuite sur allonnes yelle
safari ou latino
perdu la vue à ce moment là vous
commencez à comment a sonné et là c'est
le drame
vous dites ma vie a basculé du troisième
étage au quatrième sous-sol oui
c'est le plombier du barrio latino qui
vous dégote un meublé en banlieue à
thiais dans le val-de-marne avec intérêt
parce que tu y es c'est une ville qui
est célèbre pour son cimetière il ya
qu'à ça y'a que ça vous avez quand même
y rester 14 ans guy oui 14 14 ans dans
un petit appartement tout seul vous
écrivez à tout le monde
personne ne vous répond devrait pas la
liste
de gens qui m'ont même pas daigné me
répondre que je fous 3 2 avant un voilà
parce que là c'est la dépression
surtout qu'en plus la justice de la
canne blanche je te pas sûr de moi
j'étais abandonné je compte en plus le
plafond et comment on voit pas alors tu
te mets sur le balcon et c'est très
facile de laisser aller ouais ça a
commencé à mieux aller quand je
découvert par hasard comme tour ma vie
par un chauffeur taxi
l'association valentin oui je pourrais
citer qui est la principale pour les
handicapés visuels ça m'a un peu comment
ça
c'est sûr il y avait longtemps oui il ya
aussi kenzo oui exactement celui qui
m'attirait d'élan vital dent dans un
home studio dont le 16e arrondissement
ouverture est bien en vie bravo ce qui
m'a sauvé oui voilà
et après ça bon ben alaya on dirait
qu'il ya une nouvelle vie peut-être que
c'est un tunnel que je méritais je ne
sais pas mais j'ai pu depuis un orri
tout va bien tout va bien oui et jean
paul goude a dit que vous portiez très
bien la canne blanche
c'est vrai j'essaie mercy west hey tu
veux voir sur you save oui vous êtes
très bien ça se ressent avec plaisir de
voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'était la paix gmt
ap
et y est
habitué
[Musique]
bonsoir et un ami et maintenant c'est
dix ans aux devises au
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ou serait bien le monde à cette
grève mais trève inaba écoute à tisser
france inter ça pose pas et j'en donnais
ça me laisse le temps pour écrire des
bonnes blagues pour toi adiva politique
que française alors évidemment l'homme
de la semaine c'est lui nicolas sarkozy
a été mis en garde à vue puis mis en
examen dans la sphère du financement
libyens sarkozy va finir par être
mouillé dans plus d'un fer que nordahl
le landais
quant au contenu même de la faire alors
on a le sentiment que mouammar kadhafi
est un homme qui a quand même beaucoup
compté dans la vie de sarkozy est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est son bygmalion
mais je pense que oui
le problème c'est qu'on soupçonne
sarkozy d'avoir touché de l'argent de
kadhafi pour sa campagne de 2007 bon ben
maintenant il est mort on soupçonnait
aussi quand même sarkozy d'avoir touché
de l'argent de liliane bettencourt pour
sa campagne de 2007
maintenant elle est morte bon si ça se
trouve johnny hallyday avait fait un don
aussi bord
et comme un malheur n'arrive jamais seul
brice hortefeux a été interrogé le même
jour dans la pièce d'à côté et là je me
suis dit sarko il est foutu c'est un
petit peu comme si rantanplan venait à
la rescousse de joe dalton non
brice hortefeux a été entendu sous le
statut de suspect libre alors suspect
livre c'est aussi de petits surnoms
romantique que donne isabelle patrick
balkany
passons au reste de l'actualité
politique quand paris match raconte le
glorieux voyage des macros en inde mais
regardez-moi ça comme ils sont beaux
quand on les voit comme ça on comprend
pas pourquoi les cheminots ont envie de
faire grève mais et selon paris match
alors je cite je cite la phase même les
chèvres de la capitale s'incline sur
leur passage mais oh ouais mais nous
alors nous ça nous étonne évidemment
mais lui macron y les supporters de
l'olympique de marseille depuis qu'il
est tout petit donc voir des chèvres
s'incliner sans l'impasse sur
brutalement
[Applaudissements]
et a menacé m publication au parti
socialiste avec le nouveau patron du ps
olivier faure pour julien dray c'est une
sorte de george clooney de la politique
alors venant de la part du danny devito
de l'essonne ça doit faire plaisir alors
on notera que pour l'instant personne
apparemment n'a encore dit à george
clooney qu'il était le olivier faur du
cinéma américain
[Musique]
olivier faure qui a déclaré cette
semaine ouvrez les guillemets je
m'honore d'avoir une femme qui fait des
choix personnels oui sinon ça s'appelle
une table basse du conte
sa femme fait des choix personnels et il
sent nord bon pourquoi pas ce qui le
différencie de gérald darmanin qui lui
par choix personnel au nord les femmes
[Applaudissements]
sans transition dominique de villepin
nous donne des nouvelles rassurantes de
la santé de jacques chirac
on va pas se mentir quand ce sont des
gens qui donnent des nouvelles de ta
s'affaisser qu'elle va pas super bien
domaine mais il va mieux il va mieux
chirac bas depuis qu'il a appris que
sarkozy était en garde à vue ça l'a
rajeuni de dix ans
d'un président à l'autre dans son livre
qui va sortir bientôt françois hollande
va parler de julie gayet et de valérie
trierweiler alors les confessions de la
vie intime de françois hollande ça doit
être à peu près aussi intéressant qu'un
documentaire sur la reproduction des
morses mais
en tout cas le truc c'est que si
françois hollande doit écrire un livre
sur chaque français qu'il a baisé savoir
faire débat
politique internationale russie vladimir
poutine largement réélu un quatrième
mandat alors vous avez eue sur son
visage a surprise à l'annoncé des
résultats on dirait un petit peu à 10
algo au moment de l'attribution des jo
alors que paris était le seul candidat
il ya un électeur qui a intrigué tout le
monde au point que la fing tonnes pause
se demande mais pour qui gérard
depardieu at il bien pu voter et bah on
sait pas pour qui la beauté évidemment
tout ce qu'on peut dire c'est que ça lui
a fait tout bizarre de voir que les
urnes étaient plus bourrique lui
[Applaudissements]
et quand il ya grève à france inter je
bosse vraiment beau
et que le chi
à cause du réchauffement climatique 50%
des espèces de la planète seraient
menacés d'ici 2080 et j ai regardé il
n'y a pas de l'homme dans les espèces
donc voilà c'est rassurant le
réchauffement climatique va pouvoir
continuer tranquillement
cinéma le studio d'harvey weinstein a
déposé son bilan alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon une banque
beyrouth c'est comme une banqueroute
mais quand ça cause de ta
[Musique]
c'est mon quota de blagues raffiné de la
semaine médias encore bonne nouvelle
parce que c'est sur notre chaîne
l'émission culte de patrick sabatier
avis de recherche revient bientôt sur
ces villages ils sont contents et puis
ça démarre très fort à l'émission a même
pas encore commencé que la mission est
accomplie ils ont retrouvé patrick
sabatier
les sports à présent
l'équipe de football de mal cet accusé
l'espagne d'avoir été droguée en 1983
alors je sais pas ce que les espagnols
leur avait filé mais pour qu'il se
réveille seulement maintenant c'est que
c'était notre homme et oui
[Applaudissements]
c'était donc il ya 35 ans lors d'un
match que l'espagne mais finit par
gagner 12 1
12 1 c'est plus une défaite c'est du
viol donc sans attendre c'était du ghb
pénis roland garros 2018 le vainqueur
remportera 2,2 millions d'euros de
l'euro millions c'est l'euro millions et
et je veux dire c'est comparable parce
que quand un français et joue à l'euro
millions il a une chance sur 139
millions huit cent trente neuf mille
cent soixante de gagner le jackpot et
c'est exactement le même nombre de
chances que de son bain à deux gagné
remplacé
à l'ailé brève
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en afghanistan un bébé a été appelée
donald trump alors qu'est ce qui donne
envie à un parent d'appeler son fils
donald trump est ce qu'il est sorti avec
le placenta sur la tête passait pas on
sait pas non à un bébé c'est fripé c'est
chaud ça porte des couches a dit
n'importe quoi il fallait l'appeler
gérard collomb
aller à paris interpellé pour avoir
tagué connard avec un seul n sur une
voiture de parisse et je vous cache pas
qu'au début les policiers pensaient que
c'était un des leurs caves et
allons dans le nord là c'est le titre de
la semaine ivre virgule il plante un
couteau dans le dos de son ami croyant
que c'était par hasard alors la fête
quand même très très attention je vais
dire différencier bien votre compagne de
la pizza et puis le fpi le couteau non
non non non j'ai dire les pizzas comme
les femmes ça se mange avec les doigts
c'est la deuxième raffiné de
vous avez ri avant de siffler vous êtes
des et la dernière brève les
adeptes du joint rassembler pour la
première python cannabique c'est au
mexique et quand je constate thierry baë
peu chier nord ben je me dis c'est comme
karim benzema la coupe du monde les
français prennent pas les meilleurs
joueurs
allaient la culture
je sais que vous aimez bien chaque
semaine j'ai exposé très bien aller voir
et cette semaine paris à la villette est
exposé depuis jeudi
will rhymes and c'est un artiste
américain spécialisé dans les sculptures
et des installations gigantesques will
rhymes and c'est le fils de robert ryman
peintre minimaliste on va voir une
oeuvre de son père l'a une série
d'oeuvres de son père là on sent qu'il
ya une vraie volonté de vider le tube de
blanc et oui lui il est plutôt sculpteur
ici alors on va voir une oeuvre ces huit
mètres de long the bed ça s'appelle le
lit et on peut reconnaître assez
facilement michel houellebecq en train
de bosser sur son prochain lire il aime
les personnages en papier mâché il ya
toute une série voilà le maquereau qui
gère son gouvernement
et si on en a eu d'autres c'est joli
oeuvre d'anticipation le bureau
politique des républicains dans cinq ans
et encore ici arsenal est très joli mais
j'aime moins parce que oui on reconnaît
bien d'elazig bouteflika mais le
fauteuil roulant est très très mal fait
et enfin plus sobre voilà c'est le ciel
à la halle à giacometti un petit peu un
homme maigre qui tient son sexe et on
peut reconnaître tariq ramadan en plein
de reconstitution et
autres autres oeuvres intéressantes
clash lumsa faire c'est réglo c'est des
écoliers couler dans divers
matériau il y en a un c'est du plomb et
un cd cobalt et du graphite et a plein
d'autres voilà des enfants de toutes les
couleurs là faudrait pas qu alger
village de livanof parce que sinon elle
vouloir les adopter mais voilà
installations gigantesques une immense
main faite de capsules de bière et là la
question de l'oeuf et la poule se pose
je veux dire at-il but toutes les bières
pour pouvoir faire la main d'oeuvre
c'est parce qu'il avait vu toutes les
vieilles s'est dit ça serait super de
faire une main géante mais à la villette
si voilà c'est des heures extérieur
s'évadant jardin à la villette on va
voir notamment celui-ci voilà une oeuvre
qui prouve qu'on peut être à la fois un
grand artiste et est un joueur assez
médiocre de tetris
et celle là aussi qui est très très
belle voix lasse et bob l'eponge après
la catastrophe de fukushima
et c'est jusqu'au 16 septembre et
allez-y parce que là c'est comme la
politique c'est pas parce qu'on n'y
comprend rien beau
12 euros
j'aime c'est sûr ça m'a paru lent
tournée dans toute la france
elle me bender cinéma et l ue bravo
bravo didier bravo merci arrêté à
l'hebdo les inséparables
merci beaucoup
et maintenant par ahmad était au top de
la sienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au menu créeront le soir
vous sortez tellement de chine en ce
moment que je ne sais plus pour lequel
vous êtes là ce soir alors j'ai reçu les
dossiers de presse de l'aidant pipi et
oli qui sort le 28 mars gaston lagaffe
le 4 avril monsieur je sais tout le 9
mai je sais qu'avec par en mode d'emploi
en a l'habitude de voir tous les jours à
la télé mais au cinéma vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être là toutes les semaines
c'est parce que prévu est ce que vous
essayez pas de battre le record de kad
merad
en fait à un moment aux césars il
voulait créer une catégorie film avec
kad merad
alors il faut dire une chose c'est que
dès qu'il s'agit d'un rôle d'entraîneur
de sport fêtards ou de mec sympa qui
découvrent la paternité il ya pas photo
c'est vous un s'est passé il ya plus
personne à paris alors ce soir on va
parler de l'aidant pipi et au lit mais
ce qui l'a fait connaître d'abord ses
parents mode d'emploi
la série qui a donné beaucoup de faux
espoirs à des millions de parents alors
faisant croire qu'ils avaient un mode
d'emploi
signal ceux du maupas non vous êtes
d'accord rien absolument pas en fait
c'est un peu une série qui donne envie
de orphelins
c'est l'apologie de la vasectomie
quoi il restait lui de là à lui alors
fabrice luchini est un fan absolu vous
savez ça oui c'est incroyable il a
déclaré arnaud ducret m'impressionne et
vous a pas vu un poil
chez les plus jeunes alors il faut dire
à nos amis téléspectateurs c'est que
vous avez commencé très jeune à
ressentir le plaisir qu'il y a à être
centre de l'attention avec vos
imitations de voitures de course a
commencé à l'âge de 7 ans new way judas
born j'étais tout petit quand même donc
mon père âgé demandé par des courses de
voitures et et je m'amusais à aller
faire les bruits j'ai appris tout seul
quand il fallait sans voiture et comme
mon père adore ça si j'étais
l'attraction de la traction dernier il
m'a dit
à
non les pages leur montage de ça c'est
que ça sert à rien a compris pourquoi
les autres à son bord est
ça sert à rien mais ça permet de faire
le con promo voilà exactement c'est vrai
qu'après jean dujardin qui imite le
chameau carette boudali qui limite le
dinosaure avaient dû créer khimik la
voiture de course et obispo pallarès
l'autre et la bouche aussi ah oui le big
boss
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est très très compliqué de faire une
carrière d'acteur si tu sais pas faire
quelque chose de correct d'avenches en
promo récemment j'ai un beau gosse
chien burgos
j'suis un beau gosse
alors ne vous êtes ici ce soir pour les
dents pipi et holly d'emmanuel gilibert
avec vous et louise bourgoin alors ça
sort le 28 mars hans alors le pitch vous
êtes un célibataire endurci
vous travaillez dans la com vous avez un
super flat avec une vue imprenable sur
la tour eiffel votre colloque par à new
york et vous dis que tu t'inquiètes pas
je vais te trouver quelqu'un et vous
propose le patron d'une agence de
mannequins priori c'est plutôt un rêve
comme colloque sauf que lui ça marche
pas et il est remplacé par une très
jolie fille le problème des grades de
gosse et là vous découvrez la vie de
famille et voilà voilà c'est un drame
c'est la confrontation le choc des deux
mondes c'est le choc et je vais leur
parler d'ailleurs comme à des adultes
afpa quand même à m ouais qui vont
compléteront ce niveau aussi
alors le mauvais côté c'est que vous
tapez 2 gosses le bon côté c'est que la
maman c'est louise bourgoin corps ouais
mais bon les psychorigides à mort
allaient là oui c'est une bourge ces
oublis en tant que femme donc elle mais
que dans la réalisation et dans les
enfants à tous et casque ou letter g
divorcé en plus exactement ouais c'est
vraiment le film qui donne envie d'avoir
des enfants ou pas
oui ici la voix thierry y vous avez dit
vous vous tapez 2 gosses non non vous
prenez en charge de grues une excuse
c'est bien parce que par rapport au csa
et touria monseigneur barbarin
et le film est très bien observé parce
que le réalisateur en fait saliver
vraiment arrivé non mais comme il est il
était qu une femme qui avait deux
enfants il était dans la salle hurle
juste un gros fêtard effectivement et
voit la salle de bain il a entendu et
cette dame dire allez les enfants les
dames pipi au lit fn jean le
c'est quoi ça mais c'est un film
qui est très drôle au regard
du genre à condenser les gars c'est pas
ma chérie coco j'adore salut les filles
se balade dans sa dernière soirée dans
son labeur et à son remplaçant grâce à
qui cette colocation bas est un truc de
magal
commence à y bien plus à wade a encore
dit mme ebelle internet encore dispo
chan
quand fans
sinon t'es célibataire
8 ans et lou cinq ans la mort les
honneurs
c'était quoi ça
va voir des mannequins ces profils des
gamins
et
arrêtez pas non plus
[Musique]
là c'est la guerre les gars on ne sort
pas de table avant d'avoir terminé son
assiette
[Musique]
on
c'est pour lèveront
les templiers
[Applaudissements]
et
shah le 28 mars
alors on a dû créer vous êtes beau gosse
il
est beau gosse ou pas
ou ne serait pas elle tenait qu enfin si
une interview lover
[Musique]
arnaud qu'est ce que vous regardez en
premier chez une fille
son mec voir si voir si les plus grands
bois si je peux y aller ou pas jean luc
lahaye regarde la carte d'identité
est-ce que vous draguez beaucoup ses
charmes j'aime bien charmer c'est pas
pareil c'est la base de mon métier est
ce qui vous arrive de dire ton père a
volé toutes les étoiles du ciel pour les
mettre dans tes yeux
je dis pas à bourg et peut-être
vous mettez du temps à vous préparer
parents car bien sûr ouais bah temps
vous vous relevez votre colle comme ça
quand vous avez rendez vous avec une
gonzesse peut-être le soir à ce type
l'oac section tu veux un taxi je te
ramène ça doit être très séduisant vous
mentez sur votre profil tinda je n'ai
pas profit le team de renom mais par
contre y'a des mecs qui met ma photo sur
kindle
va faire et vous rendez vous info qui
rende gorge j'en étais et drague sur
kindle
est ce que vous faites semblant de
pleurer défaut avec les filles non pour
les séduire je suis tellement amoureux
non non non non je suis pas comme ça
marche pas comme vous en tirer
comme ça
vainqueur tatoué non non j'ai pas de
carte atout et non mais là j'ai mis
veuillez laisser l'endroit dans l'état
vous l'avez
vous fait sur la plage vous croisez une
jolie fille est-ce que vous rentrez le
ventre déjà il sort la vie
il veut pas tout faire et en plus
vous mettez du gène des voix dans mes
cheveux dans que de la science au salage
se bat pour ça tu vois que tu prends le
départ des jeunes pour le moment
est-ce que vous lui reculer la chaise
afin qu'elle se soit au restaurant et
puis surtout sortir la chaîne
c'est un gros déconneur et le
paraguay
est ce que vous faites souvent livrer
des fleurs après un premier rencart je
travaille sur ça marche ou quand la
fille est morte
il renvoie il en va du courage
ici là moi oui il thiery pas le temps
pour une autre question il est l'heure
vous êtes attendus à la nouvelle eve à
pigalle donc il faut partir maintenant
pas le temps de dire au revoir partez
maintenant c'est d'arriver au caire
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu